It is not what they'll
cover that was on the show.
They're not going to cover this, the
meat. Okay. Cause this is not my opinion.
This is the real research that I have
heard that up that I have talked to army
generals, commanding generals,
major generals, general generals,
CIA, everybody. And they're all 100%. Uh,
and I thought it was a sigh out
before and that I've researched it.
I've talked to hundreds of people now,
not on there,
but I'm gonna make a film on this
who've taken Iowasca and DMT.
I've not taken it.
And B for obvious reasons.
And uh,
and it's unbelievable because I mean,
they 100% in San Francisco is the main
project site literally have an alien base
and they are literally communicating and
they've got like astronaut level people
taking super hardcore levels of drugs
and going into meetings with these things
and making intergalactic
deals. And that, and again,
that's what the government believes and
says they're doing who this isn't that
when you say the government, that's
a broad stroke. You're painting,
you're using a broad brush. Like,
what do you mean by the breakaway?
Rogue intelligence agencies.
So we you're saying is essentially
that the using psychedelic drugs to
communicate with interdimensional beings.
Alright, that's spirit guides. Okay.
Everyone,
everyone who's done a high dose of
psychedelic drugs has had this experience.
So everyone is listening to you right
now who's done DMT or done five grams of
siliciden.
They know that this is a,
you have some kind of communication
with something else. The question is,
is that something else inside your
psyche or is that something else?
A chemical Herto crochet.
Is there a chemical doorway inside the
mind that opens up in the belief is that
when you die, and this is what the
afterlife is, that when you die,
your brain redeemed,
produces these chemicals,
these chemicals open up this doorway
and this is the portal to the next
dimension.
So you're saying,
you're saying that the government is
aware of this and they must be aware of
this.
They've heard enough people talk about it.
They must have done experiments on it.
[inaudible] to the universe for sure.
And people that have the courage
to experiment with these things.
And try them themselves realize that this
is such a profound experience that it
is.
It's so alien that if an alien landed
right now in our parking lot and a little
gray man with big black guys got out,
it would be nothing compared to what
I've seen on psychedelic trips. Well,
let me just tell you that
me getting under this Joe is just because
she'll, people need to understand that.
I don't know about this for a long time
and I just don't think people are ready
for it,
but a lot of folks who
have low oxygen and how
who and I hope brains well,
well who have sleep apnea,
have the big next big hedge
tongues go back like you and me.
You go down to 62% oxygen.
That's another time that
the brain releases DMT show.
My whole life since I was about my first
memories were every night was a DMT
trip show.
I basically,
I don't want this to sound arrogant.
It's not. I've seen everything. Well,
I believe that when you are dreaming
it's most likely the same chemicals that
are being released as well. The key
point when you go into the room sleep,
it opens the gate. Which
side is it proven? Your brain
is working in the fourth,
fifth, sixth dimension. And if
you can work into those images,
you can see beyond it. So just what
I'm trying to tell you is this,
I know you already know all this show for
your audience. Here's what's happening.
I'm not saying you're bad.
I never said you were in the CIA.
I say the CIA is on record with
Timothy leary and everybody promoting
hallucinogens in the 60s. They admitted
that it was a plan to try to, uh,
she would do in the public to
make them more suggestible,
but there's a larger program and then
they kind of backed off because he kind of
got out of control and
actually created some,
some people that were
actually fighting him. So,
so he didn't have the effect they want it.
So then they moved on the Iowasca
and the DMT that they promoted,
which good strong people that have
got compass go and have problems with,
but weak minded, stupid people and others.
Here's an example. This guy is smart. Uh,
Eric, uh, cal Mueller, syndicated radio
host. I've known him like 15 years.
You just lost me. Well, I'm going to
tell you the story you said. He's smart.
He's a nice guy. I'm just kidding.
He's a smart guy. Don't be man.
I've been on his show before. I'm
like, like she likes it. I like him to,
I'm just asking around. He will
everybody say everybody is on this quest.
And I told you, I've talked to like a
hundred people. I've talked to more.
There's a lot of people
are going and doing these,
the DMT and Iowaska trips outside Austin,
they're doing them all over the place.
Yes.
And I'm on a show and he's told me the
same story everybody tells you about
being in Peru or being,
you know, Costa Rica.
You went to two trips down
there and he shed. Yeah. Um,
we're sitting there and we
take the Iowasca and then
all these basically elves,
aliens come out of the woods and
we're all seeing the same aliens.
We're all hearing the same thing and
it's like 43 of us or whatever, seeing.
And he goes, but it was the drugs effect
on our brains. No, no, no. A drug.
Everyone sees something different.
When you open a gate and
now interdimensionally your
brain's already filtering
out most stuff because you can't handle
it. Your eyes are already seeing,
I'm like a cat when it's like
seeing something in or a dog will,
you know when they.